[موسيقى]
يعني عشرين عام من التميز ختمتها العربيه
في هذه السنه بصراحه ارقام ملياريه على
كافه المنصات نحن اليوم نتحدث عن اكثر من
مليار مشاهده على منصات العربيه المختلفه
نتحدث عن اكثر من 220 حساب في هذه اللحظه
وفي كل لحظه عم يفتح عنا حسابات جديده
[موسيقى]
العربيه كانت اول محطه توصل تصل عشره
ملايين متابع على منصه يوتيوب حاليا هي
بين صانعي الاخبار هي الاولى من حيث عدد
المتابعين نتحدث عن 12 مليون متابع على
فيسبوك كذلك الحال العربيه لديها اكثر من
30 مليون متابع ايضا على تيك توك
وبالمناسبه المنصه حديثه على صانعي
المحتوى العربيه هي الاولى الان لدينا
حوالي
مليونير متابع ولدينا مشاهدات مليونيه
[موسيقى]
لم يكون في تقطيع مباشر للعربيه على
القناه ارتفاع
ملحوظ على البث المباشر على الموقع لانه
العربيه هي مشاهده الطلعه على عشره الدول
اللي عم تشاهد الموقع
حتلاقي السعوديه مصر الولايات المتحده
كندا المانيا الامارات الاردن لانه في
عالم مش سهل توصل للقناه عن طريق
التلفزيون التقليدي فبتلاقي بيحاولوا
يوصلوا للتغطيه العربيه عن طريق الوسائل
البديله منها الموقع منها السوشيال ميديا
[موسيقى]
اكثر ببساطه كتير بحب اني اشرح للناس
الفكره لانه هي جميله جدا
ولدت من الشعار الاحب على قلب كل الناس
ومتابعي قناه العربيه ان تعرف اكثر فاخذنا
هالاكثر وديناها لمساحات اكبر عبر
السوشيال ميديا وصنعنا منها عده منصات
بتهم الناس بتهم الجيل الجديد بطريقه
شبابيه منصه بتحاكي جوانب الحياه المختلفه
[موسيقى]